parents in Germany are angry abroad a
brochure for kindergartens on how to
tackle right-wing sentiments the leaflet
was produced by a German based
foundation and the family ministry
critics allege it encourages children to
spy on parents so Peter Oliver takes a
closer look it's the season of goodwill
to all and spreading some festive cheer
right I'll spare a thought for those
answering the phones and checking emails
at one of Germany's anti-racism NGOs we
received around 450 hate calls in the
first 48 hours threatening things like
terrorist attacks
we haven't counted the exact number of
emails but it was around 500 so what is
this all about
the organization with the blessing from
the German government has produced a
brochure for kindergarten teachers and
parents designed to tackle far-right
ideology what to do if a child draws
swastikas in class and says they do this
at home what to do if a teacher is
active on the far-right scene these are
the types of situations and suggestions
on how to deal with them addressed in
the 60 page guide why all the hate
against it some of the information has
rankles to say the least with far-right
blogs as well as mainstream
conservatives a scenario is described
where a kindergarten had to deal with
children of parents involved with the
far-right the girl wears dresses and
braids and the boy faces physical
challenges and takes part in drills so
what advice do you think was given to
kindergarten staff have a face-to-face
with the parents it should be made clear
to what extent authoritarian and gender
stereotype parenting styles limit the
many possibilities of children and
complicate their development some were
rattled by the advice equating the
wearing of dresses and braids with
membership of the far-right I find it
unbelievable that a taxpayer-funded
brochure identifies girls wearing braids
and clothes as potentially nationalist
the family Minister should have this
booklet recalled and revised as soon as
possible the anti-immigration
alternative for Germany party seized on
the backlash accusing the NGO of
promoting secret
police methods the NGO denied the
allegation saying it didn't mean to cast
a shadow on how kids addressed and also
added that the brochure was
well-received by professionals this is
based on true cases truant from
long-term counseling work where teachers
have asked for help dealing with
nationalist families undoubtedly the
organization behind this brochure and
the German family ministry have the best
of intentions here however in a country
where most people still remember the GDR
asking teachers to look out for certain
political motivations could prove
problematic Peter Oliver RT Berlin
you